hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
another episode of red lips orange car
today I am joined by max Scoville hello
I'm Cassidy Moses hello it's an audio
podcast Cassidy nobody can tell if you
haven't said anything no one would know
oh you blew your cover but this is the
tenth episode of this show and it's also
going to be the last episode of season 1
taking a quick break after this so
let's get weird well I'm not even
getting weird because today I'm starting
with a story that I've been holding for
a really long time this is one of the
first ones I found and it's one of the
only romantic miss connections that I
haven't counted so you guys ready
Cassidy being rude get off the phone I'm
sorry I'm pulling up my mother about to
tell you about this age 72 year old
man's story oh okay he's got on the
computer and everything did this from
Rapid City South Dakota body average
height six-month status married which is
concerning an age 72 okay I'm looking
for a lady with the maiden name Diana
Eisenberger not sure of spelling she
would be if still living 70 or 71 years
young I met her while I was in the Air
Force at Ellsworth in 1965 while she was
studying to be a nurse at a Catholic
hospital school in Rapid City I had to
leave the base but never returned and
now I would like to find her before I
die to say I still miss you after all
these years if someone knows her please
let her know that you have ever heard
Wow
right I don't think it's said because
it's it's a 72 year old man who met
someone in 65 so that's yeah however
many maths he is a good someone else you
were 300 years ago
yeah that's at least 300 years ago he's
trying to find and still knows her name
and I it seems like they don't even at
each other for a small period of time so
if he was in the Air Force she was
studying I think that have been really
sweet about this
it's it's such a weird departure from
misconnections because you know servers
and let's name yeah it's concerned about
is this felling like go on Facebook my
dude that well if that is a good point
but like what how many 72 year olds you
know have Facebook well I guess my my
stepdad is 74 this year and he has
Facebook I know I am full and also like
their kids will probably have Facebook
so like yeah you just have to be have to
be trained in the art of Facebook creepy
well when I was home with my parents
they were trying to track down this girl
they went to school with whose sista
became a state premedia premies here
basically does she work in government
and that everyone knows in a minute her
name is Anna Bligh and everyone like
knew who she was in Queensland like just
the state that I'm from and everyone
like knew this woman and they were
trying to find her sista like I think
she's changed a loss name and we found
it within like five minutes there's like
oh hey she is you guys want to address
like we figured it out it was so [ __ ]
easy to do because it was just like
friends without apply like the weirder
thing for me to with misconnections
like max was kind of talking about this
before we started this but like it's
such a weird use of technology that is
so not necessary and I want to know if
these actually work well I mean it's
very web 11.0 where you have to like if
they had made it if they've made a
rom-com about misconnections like if
they made like a Craigslist movie I just
watched you got mail this weekend and
you've got you have got that movie is
you get the sense that the Internet is
like 200 people then yeah and that
nobody's trying to like hook up on there
that's about cyber sex okay it's really
let's just go hard my first ever cyber
sex experience was on a game called have
a hotel oh you guys have a play have a
hotel no okay so it's basically like it
was a browser-based game where I've shed
a lot of stories about this game because
I played it with such a long time where
you and like have your own kind of house
and you would like build up money but I
don't remember what you were doing
exactly but it was like fully MMO but
you were like simulating [ __ ] where you
could like go to the pool or hang out in
people's houses and they could like set
up their apartments so that it could be
like puzzle rooms kind of
series of subs like it was crazy [ __ ]
but I would have been like I don't know
ten and there were several ones that
were bleep didn't have a hotel so that
was like things that would be replaced
with the wood Baba would BBOB be a
anything that was a swag and someone
asked me if I would have se percent with
them and I was like sure that sounds
great and I had no [ __ ] idea what was
happening and then as soon as like the
conversation began and he was like
changing all these symbols to like be
sexual I was like that says ass [ __ ]
insane experience on this game where
it's really limited text boxes and you
can't sweat and someone was trying to
have internet sex with me that was it
was insane
that was something I've never had any
desire to engage with the side why
didn't do it on purpose said well no not
that specifically but I did walk into
the middle of somebody one time in
runescape this is I want to run scape
boyfriend okay okay yeah this was like I
walked into like you never got these
people just to go and like I'm just
gonna like in a text-based MMO where you
can see everyone's conversations I
remember like it was it's really good to
be cake baking that's misconnection
right there it's just hey I saw you and
your partner [ __ ] and burn scape and
gave the armor you know any more of that
would you like to quest together I've
grown up a lot since then I'm open to
some new stuff oh yeah well they haven't
any some see of thebes ones that are
like on the sea of thieves reddit where
it's been like hey we like met up last
night you were really great to raid with
like do you want to hang out again like
they're all really like wholesome and
sweet but i think the purpose of
misconnections is less about actually
trying to find someone and more about
yelling your thoughts into the void I
mean yeah like that's the Internet in
general so I was really hoping that
during e3 that we would get like III
ones and I only have this one that I
found
it's from somewhere in LA that just says
game it go you walk at Game Stop we were
low keep flowing chatting about games in
comic-con at e3 you're super cute and
I'll see you've had a boyfriend you told
me that you did but you're being so nice
to me so I decided to post here in hopes
that you'll see this I doubt it it's a
long shot okay if you do by chance I'm
gonna see this you know who I am let me
know by replying game on to this post no
it's just like say game on what color
were my damn anyone can do that and in
Cronus man can say that to you I'm gonna
break I'm assuming that's a him I'm
gonna break his heart it doesn't
actually say but I sounds like his heart
already go yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
break his heart and home she was not
flirting with you she was just basically
just be nice and she doesn't have a
boyfriend but was just a little
uncomfortable so a good point yeah that
happened to Alvin you a thing it just
says a low-key flirting chatting about
games in comic-con and I I do wonder if
like and I kind of understand this
they're like a subset of people that the
minute that you start having an engaged
conversation about [ __ ] the bed knowing
about that they take it as flooding cuz
it's passionate like you talk to anyone
about games and you're like let's get to
them yeah it don't say she was cute so
there you go
well I mean as it as a dumb dude the
sort of my takeaway from every time I've
had a female friend it was like oh no
they weren't interested that makes me
second-guess any time like I don't know
I don't know it's true okay I'm also so
[ __ ] stupid about that like this
someone who I thought was floating with
me of a text last week that I was like I
don't know if this is happening and I'm
weird about it cuz obviously have a
boyfriend I'm like I don't want this to
be happening is this person floating
with me and I asked one friend who was
like oh absolutely gross and the other
person was like no I don't think so I'm
like why does it happen I'm really bad
at picking up I wouldn't guess that like
I hate you guys interact well I wouldn't
have guessed thing is though her
roommate at one point was just like hey
Cassie likes you she was just like Oh
like I I do think sometimes it's having
a person on the outside that kind of can
this omniscient presence yeah that kind
of helps but there's two problems
there's a debate depends on who the who
the third party is because third party
is like is the dumb bro he's good like
dude she's so into you dude that girl is
number 21 she wanna [ __ ] him I think I
might be that dumb bro some of my male
friends yeah like I think sometimes
they'll be like she was she's
practically pregnant for you well
straight I'll be like she mentioned
getting to him in passing you guess [ __ ]
I'm definitely that [ __ ] bro sprint did
you try to sell you a Game Informer's
yes how you are so back to this nice old
man that's what the show is who is
looking forward I Anna Eisenberger do
you have any examples of someone that
you haven't spoken to in several years
that you could be like I would totally
get that person up again
because I struggle to think of that I
can't think of anyone that I would ever
meet that 40 years where that's a we're
not 200 years later that I would be like
[ __ ] yeah I didn't
two years ago so that's really that's a
weird one for okay well wouldn't that be
more interesting for you though but it's
like I've had a crush on her and I
didn't know the bad I do all the time
yeah where I looking back and I'm like
oh that's yeah okay that's like bad
writing though you showed up 20 years
later guess what I'm back at this time
that's an interesting question I would
have to think about it maybe I actually
I reconnected with one of my childhood
best friends and that's cool which was
yeah and we've become we've got like
really close but we were let's say we
were like super duper best friends in
like fourth grade and then when kind of
middle school rolled around she started
getting more popular and I just was with
like a weird kid so we just kind of
separated and talked for a while and
then I think we reconnected it in
college on Facebook and then she dropped
off the map again and more recently she
just hit me up was like hey I'm living
in Israel I'm married now I'm up trying
to be a flight attendant
like all right we actually bonded over
Star Wars that was it that's cuz we used
to be super into Star Wars together and
now we're just like geeking out about
like
well the great unifier yeah exactly and
it was just kind of going about it was
like it's not even just like like her
and our little sister and I were like
all talked again and it's like it's just
weird that we're like it's like she
still has a bunch of like a bunch of
mutual friends with like kind of kids
only have that with friends like my high
school best friend but it is now living
in like Russia or some [ __ ] like he's
just he's always been like a really
weird dude and like we played through
Deadly Premonition together and I have
just like so many videogame memories
with him then he's like not living like
somewhere in [ __ ] Europe that I was
like you know that checks out but when I
went to Gamescom lost I was like hey
you're around like what are you doing
he's like oh I'm walking but it's like
cuz it's Europe it's like I totally
could have gotten there but I'm walking
that day like it's so [ __ ] weird but
it's like it's with friendships I think
it's less like less weird because I
think that who you were attracted to
romantically changes so much throughout
the ghost feel like like I can't imagine
having the same taste for 40 years
Cassidy obviously goat Asus stayed
exactly the same honestly it's like the
dudes that I thought were attractive
when I was 10 just that just no not
really sure what this feeling is yeah I
don't know I can't picture this but
maybe because they will Aldo like it
says that he was nef us already and she
was studying so like they probably were
like over 20 I totally think they [ __ ]
yeah I know how to do that back then
back in 1965 I think it was just like
only missionary but they like they knew
how to do one day we'll get there all
right max what do you got for us I got a
few I got I got some [ __ ] how real do we
want to get here alright just like the
UFC yes that's what we were all thinking
alright well I'm gonna get I'm gonna
cover it to the chaser okay okay hmm
this is one's this one's pretty pretty
[ __ ] stupid
sweet so just bear with me here
[Music]
Prius full of hot girls in 7-eleven
parking lot male for male for women I
guess Santa Cruz me I was the abominably
tall guy coming out of the 7-eleven on
the corner spoiler but yes this is a
little treasure from my past now keep in
mind this is this is from 2010 yes okay
now is the abominably tall guy coming
out of the 7-eleven on the corner of
Laurel and chestnut had probably like
one or two this morning
I was with my friend who is noticeably
shorter and may or may not have been
wearing a hat I am around hair and was
wearing a leather biker jacket with a
hoodie underneath
I had the jacket all zipped up and
buckled which might have been dorky but
hey it was cold as Yeti tits last night
and be I think it makes me look like Mad
Max oh my god you bunch of girls in the
back of a bluish whitish grayish Prius
let's just say it was a breeze colored
Prius blaring justices phantom part one
we looked over at me I did the smug
drunk guy what's up head nod at you and
you all giggle oh I thought that was
awesome he probably would have come over
and said something but I didn't if
memory serves me correctly and that's a
big if you are all pretty good-looking
you are in the semi dark back seat of a
Prius and I was a little bit drunk
basically I've always wanted to listen
to electro in the back seat of a Prius
with a bunch of cute girls cool to do
that get me back I've also always wanted
to post a missed connection and this
seemed like a good excuse for it so
thanks for that but seriously I love
hanging out in the 7-eleven parking lot
and playing loud ass music we should
totally do that together sometime
incredible
this is very good so I posted that on
Craigslist Craigslist you find it I had
to dig through I have to dig through
some old emails to find this holy [ __ ]
how do you question how do you post
something on Craigslist you have to have
an email account I think and then
basically like there's it's got the if
you think a front-end of Craigslist is
ugly like the back end is even worse it
looks like you're in the [ __ ] like
sysadmin it's not even hey I mean yeah
it's pretty badly yeah so how did that
experience go well did anyone hit you up
yes uh-huh so I'm very glad but this is
I'm getting this inside the head of
7-eleven saying come and do come I keep
I keep emailing them they don't they
don't I want to do seven I love that you
specify that you look like Mad Max
that's great that's honestly my favorite
part of this is this is all seven eleven
multiple times they've got everything in
there they open they're open so late
yeah so then I didn't get a reply on
Craigslist but a friend from high school
did message me on Facebook and she goes
and this was like you know that that
summer whatever choose high random topic
in its truest form I was reading through
misconnections on Craigslist this week
with my roommates and we're ready was
opposed about people in a 7-eleven
parking lot well the writing from this
guy reminded me of you and I wanted to
share the link with you I was describing
you to the girls and they enjoyed it so
here's what a Santa Cruz style max would
sound like if there could be one oh my
god well does that mean that you
accidentally like got in with other
chicks by about you of them finding this
post though yeah God so it gets weirder
still this was a girl who I'd known from
high school and we'd always been sort of
like friends and I you know in hindsight
yes very flirty like we had we had kind
of like a just to sort of and then I was
like I messaged her back and I was like
well this is [ __ ] weird that was me I
absolutely wrote that and I'm in Santa
Cruz and she's like oh I go to school
here and so we got together holy [ __ ]
and we got just to really not not to
like upsell myself too much here we got
a plastic bottle of gin and some Tampico
which is sort of like an offer
Sunny Delight hobby I was probably
twenty one or two maybe okay twenty I
don't know what is it twenty
yeah twenty three I don't know it was
this was this was like right right
before I met Jen okay and we proceeded
to hook up in my buck in the loft bed I
was living in at the time and my friends
okay
that means you inherently win there's
the thing on this show when we talk
about all the stories and then we drank
who's likely to win
you [ __ ] won like you didn't meet the
girls you were trying to me no but you
posted the thing and you had an outcome
it was straight up like hey since high
school and it was all of that all that
[ __ ] like fantasy like hey you know
I always had a crush on you she was just
like yeah I always thought you're cute
you [ __ ] idiot like yeah that's why
I'm ester thinking of you about this
Craigslist ad
why would I say feel about the fact that
you had written me at I think she still
thought it was funny hearing and I
apparently played it off well or
something but you were just I mean that
is like written in a way that is not
creepy it's just like like good job
because most of them are written in a
way that is like hey it's like big old
titties I read one the other day that
was like - the hot pregnant redhead I
want to fan you over he's just like oh
dear God also maybe reconsider that
because that seems bad so good job yeah
digging through my other craigslist
stuff there's something else I posted
which was not as quite as serious if you
call it it's so great I love that you
have done this SF Bay Area San Francisco
Talent gigs I will give you a nickel if
you eat this bug compensation I'm Nicole
you guys see this gross bug I found it's
huge
I dare you the unit I'll give you a
nickel if you hit him don't be a [ __ ]
just eat the bug like I wasn't my
Craigslist account and the first thing
was just like one of your posts has been
flagged that I was like oh oh my god you
know okay
one story early on in the show where it
was a guy who was like hey nothing
sexual just want to hang out with you
and some balloons I particularly like
red ones you want to hang out you meet
balloons whatever that's what I was like
what was that what that is like it's
some of it just people who are like this
is gonna be funny like in between the
legs the gay dudes just know straight
dude sorry I wanting to suck penises
that's nine percent priceless but this
is brilliant max yeah also congrats okay
okay question though wait that was the
bugs part will be us is not a talent
gigs podcast this is a Miss connections
podcast is different not really the bug
got away and I spent the nickels to wake
has been a few years I'll let you know
if we have any openings posted good
thing about the girls in the car
did you want to meet them yes you did I
did okay I think they were cute I don't
know it's okay this wasn't an only
honest like some of my favorite memories
from being a teenager like full stop
we're just hanging out my friends with
really loud music gonna call like legit
I had so many [ __ ] good times where I
considered like this is before I had a
youtube channel before I started writing
in the industry I considered setting up
a camera with a microphone in my car
that would just be like Alana Anika
where I would just talk to my friends
and just like do random [ __ ] in cause
and I thought about that when I was like
16 years old oh that's right though I
wanted to do that [ __ ] forever those
because they would just like so many
moments while like we would just like do
dumb [ __ ] and that was one night web
there's a I don't know how it works in
the US but in Australia that's basically
like a certain day when you just dump
all the [ __ ] you don't want on the
street and then the council comes and
picks it up so like anything that you
know generally like family members but
anything that you don't want you just
put it on the street and they get rid of
it take away and so every single year
when that would happen we'd be like [ __ ]
yes and we would drive around and just
like fine like a weird military hat and
just like pick up
all this weird [ __ ] chubby like holy
[ __ ] what is that check up around like
playing with [ __ ] on the streets it was
the best I like totally should have
logged it but back then like vlogging
wasn't really a thing like noticed much
of a thing it was like just some of the
best [ __ ] times in my life beginning
cause I went and I got um went to the
grocery store with my friend we got a
little little zucchini or like a
cucumber or something and a bunch of
condoms and Vaseline and we went and
left it in my friend's driveway as a as
a goof which was not really it was more
of a goof on us because it's two dudes
buying a [ __ ] condoms and Vaseline
and a cucumber and like two in the
morning or whatever
we left it his driveway and we really
cause this is gonna be frequencies this
and then we kind of [ __ ] digital
camera and my friend takes a photo but
the flash is on immediately lights up
the whole [ __ ] neighborhood and my
friend who are the dude who we were
[ __ ] with who was still my friend he
comes [ __ ] booking it out of there
when he's like very large husky friend
Jordan and they just kidding Jordan's
shitty Toyota Tercel and start bawling
after his never just like running
through side yards and [ __ ] ride
doesn't [ __ ] like we gotta get the [ __ ]
out here man I get home and he
immediately like hits me up a name and
he's like hey did you do something my
driver I was like what sort of thing
would someone do D to drive he's like so
he left something in my driveway not gay
though not gay I was mean one of the
things that so I was always really
against I was always really against
bullying just in general like I was
always like if I would see someone
bullying someone else that was always
the kind of kid who would be like hey
that's shitty don't do that I was always
very like strict about that and one time
I don't remember what happened but like
a girl in my school did something shitty
whenever go on my school I never liked
its [ __ ] echo house and I was like
hey that's disrespectful her family like
had to pay for that house like you
legging that property that they walked
out mindful so I was like what if
instead we just buy flour but a bag of
flour cuz I was like no eggs
I don't like it that's hard to get rid
of someone has to clean that I don't
it's disrespectful bags of flour
Oh like a fence no it's just like a this
is like if she did something shooting
and I get it but like I'm gonna put my
foot down
so we flowered ha ha who tries to keep
the criminals from killing people like
no no no we can get him to talk
what's him in the face yeah yeah it was
a pretty stupid idea and I imagine the
next day it was all gone but we also
just found it [ __ ] hilarious like you
know like buying all these bags we
bought like five and the whole time
we're buying these bags of flowers
incredible but the family would have
been so confused what is this white
powder
what am I am one of my friends my house
second once with like a single egg like
I was sitting there watching a movie
with my mom it is I was like what the
[ __ ] just hear her like pee like oh and
I'm barely the first thing is I just go
and I just immediately write this
[ __ ] just terrifying screed on my
live journal just being like they're
funny take my house she saw it and it
scared her so much that she was afraid
to tell me for like seven years oh my
god like she's going to my wedding she's
a good friend of mine she was so scared
of me because did she do it as a joke
cuz it was funny yeah she was like this
gonna be funny I'll throw an egg at
Max's who gives a [ __ ] all the time
oh man alright Cassidy okay so I have I
was only able to find like most of the
ones that I found were either like
really creepy or like kind of weirdly
rapey and I'm like wow that's just not
that's not great right you were on
Craigslist I know but I did find three
of them and they're all relatively short
okay and they're all just garbage so
this should be fun trip to hell yeah
let's do it okay so this one is titled I
was picking up dog poo and we made eye
contact now I'm gonna read this verbatim
and it
a mess so bear with me I was sleeping in
my car and had to walk my dog was in the
Walmart parking lot went over to pick up
my dog [ __ ] and you looked me square in
the eyes you were a little thick but
that's ok
there is exercising establishments for
that so this is a horrible boy I would
like I would like to just give you a
back rub and tell you goodbye kiss face
emoji please call me if you were wearing
a faded pink muumuu please call or text
me and they put their number in here and
they have like some Roman numerals so I
had first thought that that made people
sociopaths it turns out that you'll get
flagged as spam
oh I've learned a lot of rules of
Craigslist recently that's all yeah yes
it doesn't let you actually type your
whole thing out so okay so layout of
that it's just there's a lot going on
here assuming that someone is interested
in you because they look you in the eye
yeah it's dumb also I do that
accidentally sometimes the body shaming
is not great being like hey you like
kind of fat but like you could go to the
gym that's cool yeah apples on that one
I think I think that's a prank I think
somebody took their friend's number as a
goof and they put it on there I could be
that person's getting all sorts of
[ __ ] up for me Walmart is like because
I'm from the Midwest
and Walmart is like a mythical place
there we're like it's like you're
7-eleven basically to all Midwestern
wait what no I got a water one right
like you just hang out at Walmart's some
people yeah like Walmart basically has
literally everything I've only been to a
wall-mount once
there's not many and I was amazed it was
in San Jose and I was like okay yeah
here's the thing is that of the I don't
know is 172 misconnections in the Bay
Area that popped up when I looked this
afternoon two of them were from Walmart
which is a lot like I think there was
one target there were a few other
stories sense is a thing where a lot of
people converge people yeah I think
there's also like an overlap of maybe
people who would get a boner in Walmart
and people could be using Craigslist
no that's really shitty yeah but also
I'm particularly interested in the
notion of I just want to give you a back
rub and then say goodbye tell you
goodbye I know that one
kind of stuck out to me too and like the
kiss face emoji what does that mean I
don't know back rub and then say goodbye
interesting thing about these it was
asleep in the Walmart parking lot yeah I
was sleeping in my car and had to walk
my dog wait what so that's the thing is
warmer it lets people sleep in cars or
in like Park RVs in their parking lot
like they're totally cool with that
oh so it's like a puzzle you might have
like kind of lived them maybe on how to
have us maybe Wow okay so they could
like right he's sleeping there and then
just like wake up and be like oh should
I need to walk my dog and then they see
someone who's like slightly to love the
idea of walking a dog in a parking lot
he's just hanging his dog out for a poo
he's one of those shitty dog on us he's
like you don't go to walk you just go to
go to the toilet I think that we're
taking this person seriously that's the
point that's the whole point so they're
like this connection they're like hey I
thought you were I thought you were sort
of unattractive but you can go to the
gym yeah that's great that's a really
really like I sometimes wonder if people
people don't think about the context of
what they're saying yeah like in a way
that's like this isn't gonna be
offensive it's like I I find you
attractive you're also just a little bit
big but that's compliment right I said I
find you attractive there's a lot of
that again I think it's a sort of it the
testament to who's on Craigslist okay
whip it out my next one I really love
because I have a poem in it hmm I know
why do we have the same one maybe our
poems I don't know I just really loved
it they went to the effort to write a
poem in here this is called forest girl
I saw this one I'm excited
okay it's good okay so it starts off my
heart wants to know who was that girl
was on Tuesday at 6:00 Avenue and Geary
people just I know it is it's hard to
read them because I'm very important
yeah okay the proper meter I miss you so
I thought I saw you when I stepped out
that feeling swept over me when I looked
my heart was pounding it was a side view
I thought it was you my heart knew any W
it was my common sense says let it go my
heart says she loves you though we got
into the AV rhyming here it's really
nice we just kind of transition in the
truth or dare
if our eyes lock again I will try again
and again to be like to the tune of let
it go I got another poem here if we want
to turn this into a regular please to
the girl in Embarcadero BART station
with red back I saw this financial
district to the girl with the red
backpack and short shorts walking into
Embarcadero station at 5:10 p.m. today I
wrote a haiku about that ass oh boy I
counted the syllables do all that asks
you got cheeks popping out of those
shorts I want to eat it all that ass you
got yeah cheeks popping out of those
shorts I want to eat it nailed it dude
like a adult Dora the Explorer just like
I'm like backpack shorts [ __ ] I'm a
badass that is exactly like the finance
like I love you [ __ ] gonna stop lovin
you [ __ ] I like that I wanted you know
what that might like almost be weird
enough that it would work on me Oh
totally good I would be like intrigued
total wrote a haiku about enough hmm
that is your unique ma'am that is
borderline shitposts enough that I'm
totally exactly that it's like you have
a sense of humor 100% would see was the
grandma courage like his punctuation in
grants well like outside of the hikers
spelled with wrong but other than that
is pretty nice filled with with the wide
with good wife which is the typo because
he probably it's hard to type with you
have a boner and you're at the BART
station I don't know okay
Max is going to enjoy this one good I
love a good story and is visited ICO
about eating ass I know I'm gonna read
this one exactly I think that ammeter
there's there's no contaminate this
exactly as it's written okay
7-eleven in montclair I know tell me
tell me if this is you I just max again
this is for the new guy at 7-eleven and
montclair glasses a beard and so a damn
sexy probably Oh max I come in all the
time and you seem really nice cute and
smart you're nice to everyone and I
wonder if you can handle me like you
handle the line I'm too shy to say
anything but I really wish you would hit
on me if you read this maybe we can hook
up is it all in caps is that what you
read it that way this is all isolation
points I've seen does it say like is it
man to man woman from man Oh what's
what's up with that 7-eleven is it like
you're doing this that might be a good
one do you know does he have a clear if
he cute nice it so well you gotta check
it out see that's what I come there's
one for the Safeway down the street that
was like there's like hey be that at
that black cashier it's at the Safeway
on King Street cuz I saw you looking at
me I'm gonna do it the other blog hit me
up but it was those ones that always
gets me he's like why wouldn't you just
go to the store and talk to them like if
you're gonna write out scary I think
it's weird uh if you regularly go to
this store you write something weird of
[ __ ] on Craigslist and then every time
you go to the store you're like have you
seen it like do they know what I can't
go here anymore like I think that's way
[ __ ] I think we should take the law
into our own hands and print out that
Craigslist and March it down to the 4th
and King Safeway and hand it to the
manager and say hey look with a red
backpack at the Embarcadero station are
we gonna be like some kind of
misconnection vigilantes
all right let's do it all right this one
is this one goes a lot of different
directions very quickly all right
subject line handsome black man in line
at BevMo saw this one damn it
Albany El Cerrito it's pretty it's a
pretty nice BevMo me lord mom struggling
with three Everclear bottles I want to
do whoever cleared you know what that
[ __ ] is is that like an eye drop thing
no Everclear is like 110 proof vodka
that's like it's like the most flammable
Delco it's like a Bacardi 151 and
Everclear are like the two things weight
like it's a drinkable alcohol it is a
drinkable alcohol Wow you can use it to
breathe fire if you're a Burning Man or
I was made to do that once it's that was
an intense experience it's a lot yeah so
it's a weird thing for a mom to be have
to have three bottles of it wouldn't be
for cleaning purposes well okay if you
grab them all for me and then asked if I
was partying alone really nice smile
which is like a weird sort of like I
don't know that's if I saw somebody with
three bottles Everclear at BevMo
like you need we need one maybe I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're three that's a
lot I said oh yeah well if you bring one
bottle of Bacardi 151 to a party that's
it yeah you're good one of your friends
is dead one of them dies yeah then you
get another bottle and you know deal
with it I said I was making herbal
tincture there and there is the Northern
California what is that I don't know I'm
guessing she says herbal tincture I'm
guessing like I don't know like a like
if she's gonna make a it's gonna chuck
some hubs in with her alcohol homemade
medicine I don't know if that's a
tincture I don't think you but that
sounds like a lot I mean there are three
bottles of that and then she wants to
make some Hubble [ __ ] yeah it's like a
lot of Hubble [ __ ] I don't so there's a
she going to Burning Man probably
there's a thing called a green dragon
which is where you put a bunch of
one-handed vodka and it basically just
makes it just [ __ ] you up you let it
yeah you get the weed get in the vato
that actually works that's cool
tincture is a medicine made by
dissolving a drug and alcohol there you
go they go okay so yes she's gonna put a
bunch of herbal tincture I'm guys you
can put a bunch of like st. John's wort
and [ __ ] in there but yeah again kind of
a lot you grant said something
suggestive after that like I should call
you when I was finished but I was so
flustered and nervous I didn't say
anything again this is a mom look at
nice a nice good like good-natured like
El Cerrito mom I wish I would have
gotten your number I'd like to give you
some of what I made to say thanks for
brightening up my day so I feel like it
goes from like okay oh boy here's like
this here's this train wreck mother
who's buying the highest proof alcohol
possible to be like oh she's like sort
of hippie dippie oh but she wants to
[ __ ] or does she
I don't know what if I if I was that guy
I kinda want to quite you can just be
aloof enough that you like hey this is a
nice interaction I'm gonna give you some
potential interest be like this is cool
maybe it's that total like wholesome mom
saying I think I think that the guy
would probably be like does she want to
[ __ ] me or no I can't tell like I don't
know like what's the takeaway there yeah
I mean it's a lot of social interactions
right yeah I want to call up that demo
and tell that man do you think that if
someone had a bet mobilize that much of
a high percentage alcohol that like the
person behind the counter is like hey
you okay
like do we need to talk about this but
that much in a bog Jesus Christ all
right this is the Paul was supposed to
rank who is most likely to succeed but
there are so many things that I don't
know how to do that now max wins next
wins but like as like a consolation
prize like the one that I want to
succeed the most would be
little man angry yeah that's a really
sweet one yeah beside his name is James
I like James
so masti find you what to munch on I
would read it oh the other two
consensually yeah I would read his book
full of ass poems
I absolutely would buy a book full of
black poems oh my god if it's all haikus
as well they sell that in Urban
Outfitters it just makes me think of um
hunt for the wildebeest hunt with all
the people sorry yeah where it's just
like you just says everything emotional
in haikus and maybe that's the thing is
like this guys have like some emotional
problems
Reggie Baker it's Ricky Baker's in the
[ __ ] goddamn he was in the
Embarcadero what a great movie damn I
got a lot of these should we do one more
- okay - the gal at Walmart tonight damn
it American Canyon shout out around 9:00
p.m. you were walking around with your
long curly hair and nice thin legs and
the blue bag you had over your shoulders
and I ran into a couple times and follow
you to the bathroom coincidence but I
really enjoyed the view at wish I said
something you really enjoyed the view in
the bathroom what the [ __ ] don't say
about Joey the view immediately after
following someone to the bathroom I
think he's talking about a but well I
think that's this yeah I think so too
just write a haiku yeah it's fine just
write have you this guy's gonna [ __ ]
together
I saw your butt go on the way to the
bathroom get it and I thought it [ __ ] I
thought I'd [ __ ] around on the syllabus
I want to eat it I want I wanna eat but
really enjoyed the view who wished I'd
said something now I am hoping you will
read this and respond maybe I'd really
like to be friends
Burgundy I love that one because I call
a lot of writers on Twitter and there
was like a meme going around that was
like describe yourself how am i author
would and like the beginning of that is
so perfect to what it would be your long
curly hair and thin legs and blue bags I
read a lot of casinos and it's really
funny how often they'll be like oh yes
her bosom touched up against her brows
I'll be like oh I don't know about that
or I'll be like she was aware of her
breasts it's like Tsongas yeah it's like
the dudes that should have written know
he struggled to like move her breasts
through the doorway it's like I
wowsers she thought to herself what a
pair I mean willikers why can people
find you on social medias I am on
Twitter is the best place to find me
that is at Cassidy Moser has to us isn't
to ease and I tweet a lot of gage
politics gay [ __ ] and politics I'm max
Scoville I don't know what I put on
Twitter anymore because it's Beth's I'm
on there if you want to hear me do more
awful podcasting I also do the comedy
button which is a very bad show that's
been around for far too long and weird
he which is a slightly better show
that's only been around for a little
while
thank you for joining me friends yeah
this is the last episode of season one
but we will be back and I'll announce
all the details of that on Twitter at
our LOC podcast I'll see you all next
time